your first big job in Show Business the
genius Paul Winchell who was a
ventriloquist he hired you how to you
know all this I know about you you're
amazing he hired you to be the
girlfriend of Jerry Mahoney or
knucklehead girlfriend of the dummies
the dummies and and that's a big deal
because to me Paul Winchell i i i
worshiped Paul Winchell he was a genius
yes I tried to find online you with
Jerry Mahoney but those don't even exist
those shows I right you can't find them
I don't think so and the first one I
remember uh I sang Somewhere Over the
Rainbow and I called Nanny to tell her I
was going to beforehand right that I was
going to be on the Paul winchill show
called her and she said well say hello
to me and I said said Nan I can't say hi
nanny that in right so that's when we
worked out pulling my ear so isn't that
but isn't that difficult when you're I
imagine you're nervous in those early
years on TV and you're on live
television I assume it was live uh and
you have to work in pulling your ear to
say hi to your grandmother well I
figured I would because if I didn't I'd
get hell right she would say why didn't
you pull your ear from me you know but I
always did I did it at right at the end
of the show so that was no problem did
you get famous because you sang like a
song that you wrote about John Foster
dllas John Foster dllas and then all of
a sudden that's how it got you on Ed
Sullivan and the Mo show and all those
shows yeah that was written by Ken Welch
that song got you on TV yes but I was
the girl who sang that song for a hot 10
minutes and then I was cold again it got
you on the Gary Mo show which was a
popular show at that point well uh it
got me on Ed Sullivan but Gary I
auditioned Gary would hold auditions
himself and so my agent sent me in and I
did uh a little bit of my nightclub act
that I had done at the Blue Angel that
Ken Welch wrote and everything and Gary
came out of the booth uh you know and he
said I'm going to put you on the show on
on Friday how did you persevere with all
this your mother even was kind of
insinuated you weren't pretty enough to
be in Show Business that you better not
try and pursue this you can always write
you could always write because meaning
in other words you matter
what does it make you work harder to say
hey screw you I'm going to show you how
big I can be no no that's not a driving
force I did it for me right I did
because you know I was raised going to
the movies eight movies a week you'd go
see with your grandmother you guys were
on welfare and somehow you dug up the
money to well it was double features
right and we would get in before 1:00 in
the afternoon so you get the M May price
yeah back in those days they give 11
cents for me and 11 cents and wouldn't
they give you dishes and stuff to well
that's if you wanted Bingo or whatever
it was Kino yeah Kino but they didn't
clear the theater you could stay oh yeah
yeah so I stay but in those days in the
40s Mickey and Judy always put on a show
and they made it right uh if all the
good
guys did well all the bad guys got it so
there was no cynicism in the movies so I
had that mindset when I came to New York
that yeah I'm good I'll be fine you're
wonderfully naive and it paid
off